the antagonist of the movie his
ten-year-old Michael Myers from Illinois
he has a difficult life both at home and
at school because of his shy and weird
nature and also because he's from
Illinois to make matters worse his
mother Deborah is one of the most
desirable strippers in the city one
weird thing about this kid is that he
kills and dissects animals while hiding
behind a Halloween clown costume it's
pretty weird his most recent victim is
his pet mouse one day while Michael is
engaged in his odd behavior we see his
mother dabra preparing food for the
family it is revealed that her boyfriend
Ronnie is loud ill-tempered alcoholic
and aggressive towards her he makes rude
comments about Deborah's teenage
daughter Judith and infant daughter Boo
the little girl always starts crying as
soon as Ronnie raises his voice
meanwhile Michael comes downstairs
wearing his clown mask and announces
that his pet mouse has died his mother
Comforts him and Promises to buy a new
one but she doesn't ask about the cause
of the rodent's death just then Ronnie
tells the remove his clown mask and when
Michael refuses he Yanks it off his face
later that day at school Michael
encounters a bully named Wesley Rhodes
and his friend in the washroom they
torment him by making nasty comments
about his mommy being a stripper
understandably Michael becomes upset and
begins yelling shut up while battling
the bullies alone their scuffle is
eventually ended when the principal
enters the washroom and shouts at them
however an Irate Michael curses at the
principal Landing himself into greater
problems and all three kids getting
detention in no time Deborah arrives at
the school but instead of scolding her
son she yells at the principal calling
him irresponsible shocked the latter
makes her understand that Michael is a
special child he even schedules an
appointment with Dr Sam Loomis a child
psychologist later during the evening
the doctor shows Deborah evidence of
Michael's abuse of animals and informs
her that her son displays signs of
sociopathology it turns out the
principal had found a dead cat in
Michael's school bag a collection of
images showing various anime mutilations
were also discovered Dr Loomis mentions
that these are warning indicators that
Michael might become a redditor someday
and that only a disordered mind could
take the light in such violent acts in
the meantime Michael runs from school
and stumbles upon the bully Wesley in
the woods out of nowhere he strikes him
with a large branch of a tree as Wesley
falls to the ground Michael lets out all
of his anger and hits him with blow
after blow poor Wesley who is in pain
and in tears begs Michael to stop
hurting him however the monster spoil
only becomes more aggressive and ends up
killing Wesley that evening Michael
returns home and waits for his sister
Judith to take him trick-or-treating his
mother also yells for Judith to tend to
her brother as she is about to leave for
work however the latter has no intention
of taking Michael out just as their mom
leaves Judith's boyfriend Steven comes
over and they go upstairs to have some
fun this leaves Michael all alone and
upset so he goes out donning his mask
but he comes back after a while and
finds his mother's boyfriend Ronnie
sleeping on a chair this is just the
right opportunity for the devilish child
to exact his revenge in a moment of
madness he ties the man to the chair
with duct tape and finishes him off with
a butcher knife trick or treat Ronnie
you son of a [__] a while later
Judith's boyfriend Steve comes
downstairs to make some sandwiches in
the kitchen seeing him Michael takes an
aluminum bat and Strikes him across the
back of the head Steve falls to the
floor twitching and Michael watches him
for a moment before continuing to hit
him until he is dead Michael's next move
shows him going upstairs and discovering
his sister Judith dozing in her room he
takes off his clown mask and instead
wears Steve's big white pasty Halloween
mask at the same time Judith turns
around as he runs his fingertips along
her leg she gets agitated to see Michael
in her room and demands to know what he
is doing when he doesn't respond she
slaps him in his ass filled with rage
Michael stabs his own sister in the
stomach and kills her when his mother
ultimately returns from work she
discovers him on the front porch with
his infant sister in his arms she
frantically inquires why he is out on
the porch so late Michael stays silent
while police sirens can be heard in the
background the following day Michael is
convicted of first-degree murder and
imprisoned in the mental hospital under
the care of Dr Loomis despite the cold
murders Michael pretends to be innocent
claiming that he doesn't remember
anything every week Deborah pays him a
visit but Michael seems to be growing
worse several months passed that he
continues to lie to the doctors during
one session with Dr Loomis Michael shows
him the new mask he made for himself he
claims that he dons this mask to cover
up his ugly one day his mother visits
him after a long time and tries to talk
to him however Michael is silent and
more isolated than ever she shows him an
old photo of him and his infant sister
in an effort to cheer him up and advises
him to hang it in his room but the evil
boy continues to remain silent after the
appointment Dr Loomis leads Michael to a
nurse's care while Deborah exits the
sanitarium this turns out to be a bad
idea as when the two are alone Michael
becomes aggressive and stabs the nurse
to death with a fork after a while
Deborah and the doctor find out about
the incident and become speechless in
particular Deborah is utterly distraught
now that she has seen what her son is
truly capable of it was one thing when
he killed my boyfriend and daughter but
now the nurse later she returns home and
watches old films of Michael from when
he was just a small innocent kid she
tearfully reminisces about the olden
days and wonders if she was a bad mother
probably in the end she commits the
unthinkable oh unable to Bear the pain
anymore the movie then jumps to 15 years
later Michael is now a towering man who
Still Remains locked up in the
sanitarium he hasn't spoken a word since
his last murder and spends most of his
time making masks Dr Loomis has also
given up on treating him and instead
published a best-selling book in which
he labels Michael as an unredeemable
evil one night Michael is busy making
masks when two janitors arrive in his
cell and start having their way with a
female inmate real cool Rob Zombie
Michael doesn't react
and keeps doing his work but once the
janitors are done he gets up grabs one
of them and slams him against the table
Michael then goes over to the other one
and beats him up several times before
slamming his head against the wall the
commission alerts the guard Ismail who
has been taking care of Michael ever
since he was a child soon after Ismail
arrives at the cell block and discovers
two distinct bloodied bodies scattered
over the floor as soon as he sees
Michael he immediately realizes what has
transpired he tries to lead the monster
back to his cell but the latter brutally
punishes him and finishes him off with a
television set following the massacre
Michael flees from the Asylum ready to
cause more havoc in the next scene he
arrives at a truck stop and gets in a
fight with a driver he bashes the driver
several times against the wall
eventually killing him Michael then
steals the driver's overalls and
discards his own by the next morning
which is one Halloween day Michael has
returned to his family home in
Haddonfield the place remains abandoned
since his mother's demise once there he
retrieves his favorite butcher knife and
mask in the meantime we are introduced
to Lori Strode an exemplary college
student from Haddonfield one day she is
instructed by her father who is a real
estate agent to deliver some papers at
the previous Myers residence which is
Mike
Micah turns out that her father is
trying to sell the old Myers home which
the locals believe to be haunted as
asked Lori drops off the paperwork there
and departs but to Hermes Fortune
Michael sees her and becomes curious he
then follows her to college and creeps
on her here we get to know that Lori is
often lonely and she spends most of her
Time Babysitting a neighboring 10 year
old boy on the contrary her best
friend's Linda and Annie are more
popular and loved throughout the school
later that night Annie convinces Lori to
watch her kid James so that she and her
boyfriend can have some freaking fun on
the other hand Linda joins her partner
for a party at the former Myers
residence Michael who also happens to be
there notices the couple and creeps on
them when Linda's boyfriend goes to
relieve himself Michael attacks him and
kills him on the spot he then goes ahead
and finishes off Linda as well after
this Michael makes his way to Lori's
house where he murders her parents just
like Michael do as soon as she departs
for her babysitting job his reign of
terror doesn't stop there as he makes
his way to Annie's house she is having
fun with her boyfriend Michael brutally
finishes off the ladder and then forces
himself onto Annie very cool Rob Zombie
after a few hours Lori arrives there
with James and discovers the traumatic
scene and he is shaking profusely in a
complete undressed State while her
boyfriend's body hangs from the ceiling
suddenly Michael appears at the premises
and starts attacking Lori the latter
somehow manages to flee but he follows
her and ambushes her meanwhile Michael's
Escape has been reported to Dr Loomis he
frantically comes over to Haddonfield
and begs the local sheriff to
acknowledge that Michael Myers has
returned and is dangerous the sheriff
immediately calls Lori to ask about her
whereabouts but she doesn't pick up then
after a bit of digging around he finally
gets to know the truth turns out that
Lori is Michael's sister and that she
was adopted when Deborah committed the
unthinkable the doctor realizes that
Michael is aware of this truth which is
why he has been creeping on Laurie
fearing that she may be the next victim
the doctor then makes the ultimate
decision to visit the Myers residence
meanwhile we learned that Lori is still
alive but she is being held captive the
psychopath drops his knife and hands her
a picture of the two of them when they
were little but Lori doesn't seem to
understand or reminisce about anything
as she was just an infant while he is
not looking she manages to stab Michael
in the neck and flee into the backyard
however it merely affects his bulky body
Lori is then pursued by her psychopath
brother who eventually catches her in
the empty pool thankfully the doctor
shows up at the right time and begs
Michael repeatedly to stop when this
doesn't work because obviously he shoots
the psychopath multiple times in the
back after this the doctor and Lori try
to flee but Michael miraculously gets up
breaks the windshield and Yanks her out
of the car he is about to finish her off
but the doctor starts begging him to
release her surprisingly Michael gives
in and hands Lori over to him but the
next second he grabs the doctor and
brutally kills him by gagging at his
eyes as all of this is happening Lori
grabs the nearby gun and flees upstairs
the psychopath also follows her and
eventually Corners her on a balcony he
then tackles her through the window and
they both end up falling over the
railing a while later Lori awakens on
top of an unconscious Michael she then
points the gun at him and fires a shot
but he suddenly wakes up and grabs her
wrist despite this Lori remains
undeterred and fires several more shots
at him the movie ends as Lori who is
covered in the psychopath's blood
screams hysterically Michael Myers is
finally dead until this movie makes
money at the box office then he will
come back to life
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching